Hello,
pleasure to be here.
Uh,
so I run this a submarine in Honduras right in the middle of Central America off
a island called row a Tan.
And I've been there since 1998.
And the submarine,
I'm operating,
I built myself and it's the second one and I'm here today to share,
uh,
mostly underwater pictures,
images,
give you an idea of things that live down there.
And also just a little bit of a background on how adult the submarines and a
little bit on where,
uh,
the submersible industry is as a whole.
So something that to put in context,
is there very few places in the world where people actually have the ability to
see with their own eyes,
uh,
what's going on in,
in the deep ocean?
The majority of vehicles that are doing this are run mostly by first world
governments actually.
So there's been,
in the 20 years,
I would say there's been a abrupt change between 20 years ago.
The majority of the vehicles that we're going say 2000 feet under the ocean,
we're run by a handful of first world governments.
Uh,
today the majority of vehicles that are capable of going 2000,
3000 feet deep are actually run by private individuals.
It's,
uh,
it's been the,
the submersible industry is kind of a microcosm of what's going on with funding
for science overall in the world.
I,
I believe so with the exception of China and India,
China and now operates the deepest submersible.
It's only been built and tested maybe three years ago,
but they're going seven or seven and a half thousand meters and India is working
on one that's going to be the second deepest one in the world.
To put it in context,
20 years ago,
the United States on a government level was operating five deep sea
submersibles.
And now there's only one left that used to do a hundred to 200 days of diving a
year.
Last year they only did 60.
So on the flip side,
they're machines like this one that there's five companies now,
uh,
one out of Florida,
California,
Europe that are offering basically toys for people to have on their mega yachts.
This is another one.
Uh,
this company has made over a dozen there.
They actually have a small assembly line going.
So if you're in that market,
it's a booming time.
This is a,
a boat that's operated by a foundation started by Ray Dalio of hedge fund theme.
And also if any of you have seen the new blue planet theories,
this a boat,
they have two subs on board and they're really in terms of images that are out
there that people are seeing now of the deep sea from a a man sub.
This is kind of the flagship in the world,
but it's basically privately funded with personal money.
So in the middle of this,
uh,
my little niche that I've carved out a,
it started with a dream when I was nine years old and I started building my
first sub when I was 15.
And then offering trips to the public really just became a,
it evolved into that in terms of having a way to keep,
uh,
keep the things sustainable financially.
But now it has become the world's premiere location for the public to have cost
effective,
direct access to the deep water.
It's the deepest one in the world.
The public has the ability to book a ticket on.
I'm taking people to 2000 feet.
So this is a,
I grew up in New Jersey,
just a 40 minutes or so from here.
This was in 19 eight 88.
I'm 15 years old there.
There's my dad looking on,
he joked that it was the pipe in the yard and it was for a number of years until
I brought it down to college in Florida and finished it up there.
And this a carried myself and one passenger.
It was extremely small,
uh,
in terms of this displacement,
that tells exactly where the submarine,
how big,
how big it is,
because it has to be able to achieve neutral buoyancy.
So basically an aquarium of that same volume,
2100 pounds,
uh,
there's some one person vehicles that way that,
so it's,
it was very small.
Not everybody could fit,
but it was successful largely because of its small size because it was very cost
effective to operate.
And I ran that for well solidly for two years taking passengers and a Max of 700
feet.
So I left to go do a salvage contracting Cuba.
And then when I got dropped back off in Florida,
I realized this was becoming my career and I was going to need a bigger boat.
So I started designing around to uh,
upcycled parts that I was able to obtain the forward sphere and the large dome
window,
both of which would have been out of my budget,
uh,
by themselves if I had to him new.
But I designed around those,
uh,
this is the only sub ever made of three spheres of three different sizes or
three spheres joined in an l configuration like this.
And the passenger sits side by side up front.
And I'm standing up in the back driving.
And this is actually a really good arrangement because I have the ability to
look complete.
I have awareness of everything around us,
including looking up,
but the passengers,
uh,
get closer to animal life.
You're going to see some of the photos later.
They're all taken through the dome window that the passengers are looking
through.
But we also have an overlapping field division where I'm able to see the animal
that we want to observe in relation to the window so I can get the passengers
extremely close.
So,
uh,
this was my scale model.
I originally designed it without the aid of computer design or it was a little
bit of trial and error and a little bit of educated guessing,
but done on a very basic level.
I did all my own welding,
a lot of my own machining.
I built it in a town called Oklahoma,
a town called Idabel,
Oklahoma,
the vehicles and named after the town.
The people there were incredibly supportive and it's a small town in a very
rural area of Oklahoma.
So it was kind of famous there for a bit and it worked out great too.
There was a 200 foot deep lake that a,
I was able to test it in.
Here's the components being heat treated in a facility in Louisiana.
So after you do welding on something,
a picture,
like if you put dried glue on a balloon and it,
the weld will as it's heating and contracting,
uh,
induce this stressing induces stresses into the metal.
So if you want it to be extra strong after you're done with all your welding,
you bake it in an oven at a certain temperature and that allows the tension from
the welding to relax.
That's what's going on here.
And there's the finished,
uh,
pressure hall in primer
and paint.
So the new vehicle that carries to myself in two passengers,
though ultimately that's decided by weight,
you have about 460 pounds for the passengers.
The record is six.
That was a family with a bunch of small children and uh,
it's made over 1,500 dives as deep as half a mile and is right around 9,000
pounds.
So a little more elbow room in there.
Then the first,
first version,
there it is underwater.
Okay.
So does anybody know what these animals are?
Uh,
yeah.
most of the people that,
so I see these on every dive there.
One of the oldest forms of life on the planet,
they're in the fossil record 500 million years,
which is 10 times,
almost 10 times as long as the dinosaurs were around and they've been unchanged.
Most of the people that,
uh,
I've had as passengers that know what they are,
it's because they are into studying fossils.
Okay.
And basically they're going to survive.
They only live a 500 feet or deeper and their relatives of starfish and they can
walk around
and there's a whole bunch of them on a limestone arch.
That's it.
1200 feet.
Okay.
And this is a closeup of the terrain between 300 to 600 feet where I'm diving.
It's a vertical trench wall.
I'm on the edge of the Cayman Trench and there basically a band of rock around
most places in the world that looks very much like this photo here that is a
drowned ancient reef from when sea level was 450 feet lower than it is now.
So
when the sea level was that much lower,
the shallow water reef was growing there,
which puts a layer of limestone on things,
which is what this is.
And uh,
but then when sea level rises,
the coral reef dies and then the rock that it created slowly dissolves and make
something that looks like this.
So actually a lot of the shallow water reefs around the world,
if things continue at the pace they're going may one day look sort of like this.
Okay.
To give you a sense of scale,
the corals on here,
the white ones are one to two feet across.
Something else that's very surprising to people when they take trips with me is
the clarity of the water.
People think that it's going to be very dark down there.
But,
uh,
actually what happens is it about 300 feet,
there's a major thermocline and the visibility of the water skyrockets to the
point where you can see 300 easily.
You could see across this whole room with natural light,
a thousand feet underwater.
And I've seen the surface from 600 feet.
So these are six skill sharks.
I've,
uh,
done close to a hundred dives with date where we go at night and have the bait.
We used to stick it out at the end of a pole,
but we've,
uh,
I've developed enough of a,
the sharks,
their metabolism is very low.
The water down there is below 50 degrees,
so they,
they're not super aggressive.
They're big.
Uh,
to give you a sense of scale in this photo,
that window is 30 inches across.
So these sharks,
they get 16,
18 feet long.
And I've had a theory for years that nobody that I've spoken to is even been
able to offer an alternative.
But these are most likely the most numerous animal over say 200 pounds left on
the planet today outside of humans and their livestock,
their found,
uh,
pretty much worldwide.
But in tropical waters,
they prefer,
prefer to be three to 5,000 feet during the day.
So they have basically been left alone.
They're too big for people to,
it's not worth the hassle yet for people to fish them that deep and pull
something up that big from that,
you know,
that heavy from that deep.
Uh,
this,
uh,
Jeremy Wade,
about a year ago we shot an episode of river monsters.
We had an 80 pound pig on the bumper there.
We did a series of dives to a film,
the six skills.
And again,
to give you a context of scale,
we had a Gopro in a custom housing on the end of a carbon fiber pole,
uh,
that got the shot and you can see the sub relative to the size of the vehicle.
And can we play that video now please?
That,
uh,
sound in there,
the scratching noise was actually their skin against,
uh,
part of the sudden they have a surprisingly tough skin of attempted tagging them
and they're,
they're very tough.
Uh,
this was a dive I did with National Geographic.
This was a,
we were lucky enough to come across a horse that,
uh,
met an unfortunate end.
We had five sharks in a feeding frenzy.
But,
uh,
again,
you can tell the size scale in that photo
that was,
uh,
the shark was large enough.
It was able to swallow the entire horse leg in one bite and they're deer on the
island.
My neighbor,
uh,
keeps a few as pets.
One died of old age and I did a shark dive and that was this photo.
The shark was able to eat the whole deer one,
one gulp.
So this is another kind of shark that,
uh,
I might actually have more direct observations of then any,
anybody ever.
They don't,
they're only about two and a half,
three feet long.
And they live starting at around a thousand feet and they have these two big
dorsal fins.
The forward one has a poisonous spiking in it and they have a mouth,
kind of like an eagle gray where they dig in the sand for things that are buried
in there and they
okay,
uh,
crunch them up that say a lucky shot.
Sometimes I do a dive with a Gopro on one second timelapse on the front bumper
and just by chance got that shot.
So in that photo you can see the underside of the shark has those ribs.
Uh,
much like a hammerheads head has the electro magnetic sensing that it can detect
like say a ray buried in the sand.
This shark instead of just its head being like that,
the entire underside of its body is like that.
So in this low light environment it's able to send small things buried in the
sand.
And this I believe is the only photo of a baby rough shark.
I've only seen two and this is the better photo.
This is a dumbo octopus.
They swim it their ears.
They only started around 1800 feet.
1800 feet is a significant depth.
That's where it's really getting
down to total blackness,
which is not only the majority of this planet is covered by water.
So deep it's never seen sunlight.
But also by volume you're talking something like a 700 to one ratio.
Volume wise,
the,
the living space of this planet is really cold,
dark water.
So a lot of animals,
that's specifically what they're evolved for and this is one of those animals.
This is a deep,
deep water coral.
The red thing on there is a starfish and that's about two feet in diameter.
Very little is known about deep water coral.
Uh,
we're just starting to study it now.
A few countries are putting some resources to figuring out what,
what they have in their territorial waters,
but what they've learned so far is that there may actually be more area of deep
water coral,
then shallow water coral,
despite the fact that a majority of it might about already been destroyed by
trawling.
But there's certain areas where the habitat is so jagged where people avoid
trawling that is relatively untouched.
And in those areas,
uh,
you know,
it's this complete,
completely separate deep water environment that rivals a shallow water reef.
But usually these start at around 600 feet.
It's kind of a shallow one.
The ones by me,
they really start more around 1200 feet.
So there's that barrier to entry that has kept them from being a better studied,
are well known.
This is a type of sea cucumber that can swim.
Yeah,
this is a Kymera that's half shark half ray.
They have no cartilage.
That's the animal.
My logo is based off of,
this is a predatory jellyfish called a siphon of four and they have stinging
tentacles.
They can catch small fish.
A certain types of SciFinder force can be a hundred feet long.
That's a jelly,
no zeal.
They get to about five feet long.
So this is a aerial view of the island where I live and you can see that
there is not a,
so where that boat is on the left,
that's already four or 500 feet deep right there.
Basically the island is surrounded by incredibly deep water and actually part of
the reason I'm here is uh,
is like a little bit of thank you to the Schmidt Ocean Institute,
which uh,
with this boat,
the Falcor that they run.
Uh,
they had been doing a project in the Cayman Islands and then we're relocating
through the canal.
And a scientists that had worked with them had worked with me and realized that
there was a unique opportunity here to do some multibeam sonar work,
which is usually it would be the very first thing that would be done before
putting any assets like a submersible or an Rov in the water.
In this case,
uh,
I had been operating for more than 10 years.
When was,
I was able to finally have a map.
So this is the map that
the Falcor generated while they generated rod date data.
And then they gave that data to an Undergrad student of this,
uh,
scientist.
And then a couple of months later they made this map but basically shows a major
erosion channels,
features after basically after more than a decade of driving around down there,
basically the blind man looking at an elephant,
I was able to see a photo of the entire elephant for the first time.
So it was amazing that worked out like that.
And to give you an idea of what kind of detail a map like that can do.
Those lines are a hundred,
a hundred foot increments and the dark spots or boulders.
So thanks to this map,
I can actually
have a map in my lap when I'm driving around down there and know exactly where I
am relative to other features.
And also it enables me to find better areas that are conducive to things like
deep water coral.
In this example a,
those red circles are boulders that are 50 to 100 feet high and they're all
completely covered with deep water coral.
Okay.
Which sets off a whole community of life.
I mean there's where there's rocks covered with coral,
you have more fit,
more everything like very unique habitats.
So actually the biggest obstacle to a more life being down there is
sedimentation.
Uh,
so on the top of there you can see it looks like big lines coming off.
Those are erosion channels that are up to 600 feet deep.
Okay.
Everything being so steep,
erosion is a major factor.
Sometimes even see what looks like a waterfalls of sand coming down vertical
areas.
So that hinders life.
Being able to,
to take,
uh,
take a foothold picture,
you know,
a plant trying to grow on the screen side of a mountain where there's a glacier
moving.
That's a similar situation to what's going on here.
Actually write down two blocks of rock peeling off the wall and much like a
glacier calving,
there's limestone blocks even at 2000 feet bigger than this room that the very
fact that it's limestone shows that it was made by coral.
So it the deepest that it fell from with 700 feet and it broke free and rolled
down there.
So animals,
uh,
when they can find boulders like that to get on top of,
now they're out of that flow of sediment and that's where they have their best
chance of surviving.
And if you get a bunch of boulders like that in one area,
now you have critical mass for a whole community to really flourish.
So those are the kinds of things that I'm looking for with this map that the
Falcor generated.
And so because of that map,
uh,
I've now made this device,
which I call the sub sled and the submarine docs in there.
This,
this,
uh,
floating sled.
It's made out of fiberglass and PVC fiberglass reinforced board and it has three
ballast compartments and basically you can put it in the water,
flood the tank so it sits real low,
drive the submarine in it,
then partially inflate the ballast compartments and you can tow from the
submarine itself.
The water pressure keeps the,
the sled pushed on the front of it.
Uh,
they're,
the two of them are made it together
and now instead of towing at about three miles an hour,
I can tow it about seven miles an hour.
And in addition to that,
it makes it a lot easier to get in and out of the submarine in the middle of the
ocean,
which was basically unsafe in anything but super calm seas previously.
But with this arrangement you can get in and out in about four to six foot seas.
So basically thanks to the map that the Schmidt Ocean institute generated.
It's opened up a new error of exploration for,
for me around [inaudible] to go and explore new spots.
And there is a parting shot of a hammerhead cruising down the wall.
And now I have another video that I'll,
uh,
talk through a lot of the same animals we've seen,
but you'll see how they move and then we'll have questions.
Yeah,
you only really need to hold the hatch tied enough just to put pressure on the o
ring to seal for the first couple of feet and in,
once you get under water,
the pressure seal said for you
that's cruising along the top of the second wall,
which is also where the thermocline is.
There are a lot of animals pelagics like,
uh,
different kinds of sharks,
Mantas,
tuna,
that that's your best chance of seeing them as along the top of that second
wall.
Okay.
That's a type of deep water sand tiger shark.
Yeah.
This is a pirate zone,
which uh,
this one's about eight feet long,
but they can get over 20 feet long and they actively swim.
They're called pirate zone because Tyra for Greek fire,
they're capable of making a very bright bioluminescence.
This is it about 500 feet films with only natural light.
Everything looks very blue down there be with no artificial light because that's
the only color left in the light waves making it down there.
This is another kind of siphon of four that you only start seeing it around 2000
feet and they connect themselves to the bottom with a little tentacle arms about
three feet off and if you get close to him,
they swim away.
And this is a wonky eye jewel squid they have,
is it another kind of fish?
Was there a squat lobsters on a sea fan?
About eight feet across.
Okay.
This is a new drink that's about the size of a football and they live pretty
much only between 710,000 feet and are nocturnal and if
you hang out by him too long and disturb them,
they jump off the bottom and swim.
This is a giant isopod.
They can get about a foot and a half long.
When I go with Bait for the sharks,
they're often show up.
This is a polychaete worm.
They're very common on sandy spots below a thousand feet.
They look like a little yellow slime ball,
but then can jump up and swim.
This is a orange roughy,
one of the worst fish to eat.
The only way they catch them is deep water trawling.
They live over close to 200 years old.
This is a sea cucumber.
They're very common.
Some dives,
I might see 100 of them and usually they just sit on the bottom.
Every once in a while they get a sniff of some food somewhere and they jump up
and swim for a while to relocate is the Dumbo octopus and action
to six scale.
Again,
scientists like to have these scaling lasers on the sub.
They're 10 centimeters apart,
so like right now you can freeze a frame of that and measure everything on the
shark.
Precisely.
So what looks like worms on there are actually starfish called snake stars may
have symbiotic relationships with the corals.
This is a kind of angler fish and they have four legs and a little lower between
their eyes.
They can swim but they prefer to waddle.
That's the same type of starfish we saw in the still of the deep water corals
there.
Brisson good starfish there.
Pacific and Atlantic.
And this is a Venus fly trap,
an enemy.
This is a sea Robin.
It's got prongs on its face that it can dig in the dirt with and its pectoral
fins have evolved into clause that it pulls itself along the bottom with,
this is a,
another kind of siphon a four.
When you first approach them there in like a spiral chandelier
that's about a foot long
and about
2,400 feet.
Okay.
Think that's it.
Any questions?
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you for,
for your talk.
I'm in all of your engineering abilities.
How do you not die when you do these things?
I mean,
what,
what is your approach to,
to safety?
How if you learned to make these dives safe and um,
what kind of sort of redundant safety measures have you built in your,
in your
well,
so the way that I educated myself on,
on how to build a machine like this and not die was going and meeting with as
many people as I could that had expertise at doing such things and also
physically looking at other vehicles and basically taking careful notes on how
they were constructed.
One thing that really works to my advantage in this,
uh,
the first one was a cylinder and the new one is a series of spheres.
But basically if you're going to go below a couple hundred feet,
you have to be some combination of cylinders.
Are Spheres,
the circular shape and it's a scalable problem.
So you can't,
and they're only a certain types of steels that are preferred to use for
pressure vessels.
So your,
your variables are fairly limited in terms of what you're left with is,
you know,
you can extrapolate.
All right,
this,
this submarine was made out of that kind of steel,
went this deep and was a circle of this thickness.
And it was really kind of working engineering from that where where I managed
to,
you know,
build a safe craft redundancy is
uh,
a big thing in submersibles I have.
So I waved my passengers before they get in and when we fled the battles
compartments were only sinking by maybe 10 or 20 pounds.
And then we have two separate high pressure air systems where we're able to add,
uh,
Erda to two separate ballots compartments where we could gain over 1,500 pounds
of bland seat.
And we also have a single bolt we can turn and let loose about a 350 pound a
block of led.
We also carry three days of air.
And the submerse bill also has fully redundant propulsion systems because of
where I operate most submersibles,
uh,
when it have fully redundant propulsion and if they had a motor failure,
they would simply surface and call their support ship.
But I'm operating without a support ships.
So I,
uh,
because of where I operate,
I'm only 800 feet from the dock to the trench wall.
But the flip side of that is if I came up and the wind was blowing me back
towards the reef,
by the time of boat came to Tomi in,
I might be up on the reef.
So in addition to those other things,
I have a separate battery banks,
four motors when I only need two separate switching.
Okay.
And so even though the motors I use aren't the most reliable kinds,
they're,
they're brushed motors instead of,
you could spend 10 times the amount for brushless motors,
but I have motors fail maybe once or twice a year.
And my passengers never know because I have a complete second set.
Thank you for coming in for presenting to us.
Uh,
chuck questions.
What was the best and the worst moment for you doing the dice?
Yeah.
Um,
well,
the best moments are when I see things that I've never seen before and that
sense of discovery and awe and
just not knowing what you're looking at,
which I think is in like a way I'm a,
I'm a little bit envious of people that traveled before photography.
And you only had a,
you know,
like a rough sketch or even imagine being like the first people crossing the,
the continent on wagons and coming across the Grand Canyon and not even having a
full concept of what you are going to see versus like now you can look at
somebody's photos on trip advisor and like pretty well understand what it is
before you ever left your house.
Uh,
in the deep ocean.
You can still have that sense of on discovery because they're literally,
you know,
I'm discovering new species with scientists that they're flipping out and
they're the world experts.
Uh,
the,
the worst moment I've ever had in the sub was I surfaced after about six,
seven hours from a shark dive at night and the weather had deteriorated,
deteriorated to the point there was probably eight to 10 foot waves that were
almost rolling the submarine completely over.
And I had to get through the channel,
which is about as wide as for me to you.
And in addition to all that,
there was a power outage on shore.
So I had a compass and I knew I was looking straight at the island,
but I couldn't see it because all the lights were out.
But I didn't realize that.
I thought it was in addition to all right,
these waves are bigger than anything I've ever been in in the waves are so big
they're blocking my view.
So that was fairly terrifying.
Yeah.
Hi,
thanks for coming out.
I saw chasing coral last year was like really hit me hard about,
you know,
the impacts of climate change and the ocean.
I was just wondering if you've actually personally seen any changes in any of
the dives you've done over the last few decades that you think are attributed to
climate change.
Um,
we just had our first bleaching event where I live,
but,
uh,
fortunately the quarrels off of Honduras or doing a pretty good job of
rebounding the reef is relatively healthy compared to the rest of the
Mesoamerican reef.
However,
in the 20 years that I've been diving,
I would say I,
I have definitely seen a marked decline in large pledge IHC species or pledge
like tuna and hammerhead sharks.
I think their numbers have come down 90% in 20 years.
And on the flip side,
the amount of plastic in the ocean is skyrocketing.
And I definitely see evidence of that.
I read on your website about how you had a,
uh,
a failure with a window cracking and I was wondering if you could tell us about
that and then maybe,
uh,
why you think the window cracked?
Like what was the failure mode there?
Yeah.
Um,
well
I'm not sure which story was on the,
uh,
the website.
There's been actually,
well windows cracking,
but the,
uh,
that one was the,
the first sub and I designed it for 600 feet and then I kind of kept pushing it,
uh,
and took it down to 725 feet.
And shortly thereafter,
actually on the way back up was the first window cracking in.
The most dramatic of all of them were basically crack right through the middle
and water was spraying in the passengers space.
But we surfaced in a couple of minutes with maybe five gallons of water in
there.
I had the presence of mind to,
uh,
take his camera and wrap it in a towel.
Nothing got damaged.
But,
uh,
basically what happened was the entire hall was being tweaked to where the
window wasn't being pressed flat against the surface anymore.
It was being twisted and that was what caused the failure.
So,
so when the submarine was coming up at untwisted very quickly,
it's a,
there's a time factor,
basically like had I just stayed at the 20 feet deeper,
a couple minutes longer,
it's still what a cracked it was.
A with plastic,
much like a glass windows.
Eventually like start getting droopy on old enough buildings,
a plastic window on a submarine.
Uh,
let's say it a thousand hours underwater.
It's actually half as strong as it was when he first got down there.
So it,
it was the time factor.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
Um,
the island,
you chose what's,
what,
what's it called?
Row a Tan.
It's,
it's beautiful.
What other locations would be ideal?
Like if you couldn't go there?
Yeah.
Um,
I've invested a great deal of energy looking at other locations and traveled to
a good number of them as well.
And Road 10 is actually pretty close to the ideal location.
Uh,
you need deep water close to shore,
preferably on the lease side of an island,
no strong currents,
uh,
close to an international airport and a customer base.
And most of the other places around the world that have those things already
have a cruise ship port,
a commercial,
a shipping port,
uh,
military.
But like for example,
the tongue of the ocean in The Bahamas.
Great location.
There's been a military navy base for submarines there since I think the
fifties.
Uh,
Bahamas has great spots but has cruise ships that,
so there was another operation in the Cayman Islands and for example,
when they were operating there,
they had to share the same harbor with all the commercial traffic for the
island,
whereas the bay that I operate out of,
so the island has so many natural harbors,
I would say 30 for a 40 mile long island that every entity has its own harbor.
It's really an ideal spot.
And how long does it take to fly there from here?
Um,
two,
two hours.
That's really close.
Yeah.
Awesome mate.
Two hours from Houston United flight.
We have direct flights from Miami and Houston and Atlanta.
You talked in the beginning of your presentation about the advancements that
have been made in the last 20,
30 years since you first started doing this.
[inaudible] curious to hear of what you think in the next 20 years,
what the next big thing has to happen in the industry.
MMM.
I think a three d printing has enormous potential for making a hall that picture
like a bird's bone and how it's a matrix of mostly space,
but has an internal trust that's giving it incredible strength and lightweight.
The limiting factor on how deepest submersible hell can go is strength to weight
ratio.
And that's why,
uh,
some submersibles,
well they're testing one right now that's made out of carbon fiber that will be
for 4,000 meters and we'll be the deepest privately owned vehicle of its kind.
Uh,
carbon fiber has a lot of potential,
but if you could do something like three d,
print out a titanium or aluminum or you would have something that could go
almost full ocean depth very affordably.
Right now all the 6,000 meter submersibles rely on a titanium sphere,
which is millions of dollars to create extremely technical to weld,
like has to be done in a vacuum chamber with a laser beam and is still won't
float.
So to counteract all the weight of that sphere,
they have to use very expensive foam that has glass micro spheres in it.
And then you've added a,
you basically doubled the overall vehicle weight by just putting all this foam
on it,
just to counteract the weight of all the metal you had to put into the hall.
If there was a way to make three d print that where maybe it was three times as
thick,
but it was mostly airspace and internal trusses,
which would be a nightmare to,
you know,
manufacturer in any traditional way,
that would be a major breakthrough.
Hi.
Um,
so you,
you bring a lot of like civilians and down to the bottom of the ocean.
Yeah.
Uh,
I read on your site that to like see one of those six skilled sharks,
you've gotta be prepared to like be down there in total darkness for like eight
hours.
Do People Freak out on you?
I'm like getting claustrophobic looking at this slide show.
No.
Uh,
I'm actually never had anybody freak out underwater.
Every once in a while,
somebody,
when they first get in on the dock,
they get back out.
But I think they,
uh,
you know,
they've been on the website,
then they know what they're in for.
And actually,
um,
even though it's a,
it's a confined area to spend that amount of time in and it's cold and a little
uncomfortable when that shark swims by,
all of a sudden,
it feels like a very safe place.
[inaudible].